Let's begin with a discussion of the World Wide Web.
The World Wide Web is a collection of HTML documents.
These documents are made up of something called HTML,
which stands for HyperText Markup Language--
this is the basis for almost every webpage.
Even though there can be--you know--
documents, images, videos, and--you know--
all sorts of things online,
HTML is what glues everything together.
And the links between these pages,
called hyperlinks--or links for short--
is what makes the web web-like.
The web was invented in the early 1990s,
and has something on the order of 30 billion pages.
Time for the first quiz.
What is the main type of document on the web?
Is it HTML? Microsoft Word documents? PDFs?
Or plain text?